- Mein Name ist Bernd Schöllgen.
Ich bin Diplomingenieur,
hab allerdings den Beruf
des Anlagenmechanikers
– damals hieß er noch
Gas- und Wasserinstallateur –
auch selber gelernt und ausgeübt
und bin jetzt seit 1.6.2002 hier in der
Firma als Geschäftsführer tätig
und auch als Gesellschafter.
- Mein Name ist Patrick Hemme, und
ich bin Anlagenmechaniker, gelernt,
und hab die Ausbildung vor circa
anderthalb Jahren abgeschlossen.
- Ich bin der Andreas Mandt,
ich komm hier aus Alfter.
Ich mache jetzt seit zwei Jahren die
Ausbildung zum Anlagenmechaniker
im Bereich Heizung, Sanitär-
und Klimatechnik.
- Es ist sehr, sehr vielfältig.
Es ist abwechslungsreich:
Man hat mit Kunden zu tun,
man hat mit Kollegen zu tun,
man hat im Team zu tun, man ist auf der
Baustelle, man ist auch in der Werkstatt.
- Die Hauptthemen sind
natürlich Badsanierung,
Kesselsanierung und im
Bereich Kundendienst,
wo kleinere Reparaturen
gemacht werden
und Wartungen an Kesseln
durchgeführt werden.
- Als Anlagenmechaniker
ist man viel unterwegs.
Typische Tätigkeiten sind
zum Beispiel Wartungsarbeiten.
Anlagenmechaniker kontrollieren,
ob die Heizung richtig funktioniert.
Sie machen auch Reparaturen
– zum Beispiel in Badezimmern.
Sie bauen komplett neue Bäder ein
und installieren Fußbodenheizungen.
Mehr über den Beruf des
Anlagenmechanikers
erfahrt ihr im nächsten Teil.
- Morgen zusammen.
- Morgen.
- Guten Morgen.
- Sprechen wir mal den heutigen Tag durch,
… damit ihr starten könnt. Also wir fangen
jetzt heute Morgen an bei der Familie Jäger
mit einer Wartung,
eine Ölheizungsanlage, ja?
Einschließlich Warmwasserspeicher, ne?
- Kein Problem!
- Ja, wir überprüfen die
Gasleistung … das Übliche.
Da hab ich einen Termin vereinbart
zwischen 8 und 9 Uhr.
Ja, als nächstes, zwischen 10 und
11 Uhr haben wir ein Füllventil
bei der Familie Schürmann – Füllventil
am Spülkasten zu tauschen.
Und der Rest vom Tag ist
dann wahrscheinlich
auch ein sehr anstrengendes Programm,
könnte auch eine Stunde länger werden,
bei der Baustelle im Himbeergarten
22 in dem Badezimmer
bei der Badsanierung die Fußbodenheizung
muss noch fertig verlegt werden.
Und die muss heute aber komplett rein,
weil morgen schon der Estrich gelegt wird.
Okay, hat der Estrichleger was
mit der Unterdämmung zu tun
oder machen wir das?
- Das machen wir alles komplett.
- Alles klar, gut!
Ja, wir brauchen einmal unser Füllventil.
- Ja. Hab ich.
- Dann brauchen wir unseren
Dichtungssatz für die Wartung.
- Ja okay.
- Und als Nächstes brauchen
wir noch unsere Verschraubung
für die Fußbodenheizung.
So, dann haben wir unser Material,
jetzt brauchen wir noch unsere Geräte.
- Genau. Weißt du denn,
was wir alles brauchen?
- Du nimmst bitte einmal die
Pressmaschine mit und …
- Und die Überziehschuhe, ne?
- Und die Überziehschuhe.
Und jetzt haben wir noch den Messkoffer,
den packe ich noch mit ein.
Warte, ich mach dir die Tür auf.
- Hier ist der Heizungskeller und …
ja, einmal bitte warten.
- Natürlich. Wir werden jetzt
hier was auslegen
und uns danach um die
Heizung kümmern.
- Okay, danke.
- Dann werden wir uns
mal um die Heizung kümmern.
Was müssen wir als
Erstes machen?
- Als Erstes mal den Brenner aufmachen.
- Ausschalten. Wir müssen
den Brenner ausschalten.
So, die Heizung ist aus.
Und nun werden wir unten
mal sauber machen,
uns mal angucken, wie der
Brennerraum aussieht.
Du holst jetzt bitte mal den Staubsauger.
Und dann werden wir mal den
Brennerraum aussaugen.
Kannst du den Sauger bitte wegräumen?
- Was wird als Nächstes gemacht?
- Als Nächstes werden wir
den Aschebehälter ausleeren.
Andreas, gehst du bitte mal
den Messkoffer vom Auto holen?
- Ja klar, mach ich.
- Gibst du mir bitte das Messgerät?
- Was gibt es denn für eine
Obergrenze für den CO-Wert?
- Also beim CO-Wert ist es so, dass der
immer möglichst tief sein sollte.
In der Regel liegt der so bei 15.
Aber wenn der dann höher
schießen sollte auf bis über 500,
dann wird die Anlage
sofort stillgelegt,
weil das schädliche CO dann in zu hoher
Konzentration in die Luft kommt.
- Okay.
- Aber das hier, das passt so weit alles.
- So, war alles in Ordnung?
- Genau, wir haben Ihre Heizung gewartet.
Mit der Heizung ist alles in Ordnung.
Ich hab hier unseren Zettel fertig gemacht:
Wir haben die Anlage gewartet,
wir haben auch die Abgase
gemessen – das passt alles.
Da müssen Sie sich keine Sorgen
machen. Wir waren so lange hier.
Und da bekomme ich bitte von
Ihnen dort eine Unterschrift.
- Gerne.
- Super, ich danke Ihnen. Ich wünsche
Ihnen noch einen schönen Tag
und wir verabschieden uns.
- Einen schönen Tag noch, tschüss.
- Schönen Tag noch!
So, Andreas, wir werden jetzt
das Füllventil wechseln müssen.
- Okay. Warum?
- Weil der Spülkasten durchläuft.
Das heißt, das Füllventil schließt
nicht mehr, und durch den Überläufer
läuft das ganze Wasser in die Toilette rein.
- Okay.
- Dazu werden wir die Platte
abmachen, die Sicherungen lösen,
die Halter herausnehmen.
Packst du bitte das neue
Füllventil schon einmal aus?
Dann können wir den
Überwurf abschrauben …
und das Füllventil wieder einschrauben.
Das ganze Füllventil an alter
Position wieder montieren.
Und jetzt muss man das Ganze
rückwärts wieder zusammenbauen.
So, das war’s.
- Guten Tag, Frau Broichhagen.
- Guten Tag.
- Die Firma Schöllgen. Mein Name
ist Hemme. Das ist der Kollege Mandt.
Wir sind hier für die Badsanierung, wir
legen heute die Fußbodenheizung.
- Ja, schön, schön, dass ihr da
seid. Kommt bitte rein.
- Danke schön.
- So, Andreas, wir sind hier
jetzt in dem Badezimmer.
- Ja.
- Wir haben folgende Situation:
Wir haben da vorne den Waschtisch,
hier kommt das WC hin.
Und wir sind heute hier, um
die Fußbodenheizung zu legen.
- Alles klar.
- Wir haben die Fußbodenheizung
verlegt, wir haben sie angeschlossen,
und sie ist dicht. Und damit sind
wir fertig für heute.
- Ja, klasse. Vielen Dank.
- Ich hab jetzt Ihnen den Zettel fertig
gemacht. Das bin ich, das ist der Kollege.
Heute, und wir waren jetzt insgesamt
drei Stunden hier gewesen.
Wir haben die Fußbodenheizung verlegt,
angeschlossen und auf
Dichtigkeit überprüft.
Und dann bekomme ich bitte hier
unten eine Unterschrift von Ihnen.
- Sind das jetzt insgesamt
dann sechs Stunden oder?
- Drei Stunden für jeden.
Also insgesamt sechs Stunden.
- Wo soll ich unterschreiben?
- Da unten bitte, beim Kreuz.
- Ja, danke schön.
- Vielen Dank Ihnen.
Dann wünsche ich Ihnen
noch einen schönen Tag.
- Danke schön, gleichfalls.
- Tschüss.
- Bis dahin, tschüss!
- Das ist ein sehr, sehr
abwechslungsreicher Beruf
und er ist auch ein sehr
anspruchsvoller Beruf.
Man hat mit Trinkwasser zu tun,
das ist Lebensmittel Nummer eins,
man hat mit Energien zu tun,
mit Gas, mit Öl, mit Pellets,
mit Wärmepumpen,
modernsten Techniken.
- Man sollte auf jeden Fall
Spaß am Handwerk haben
und auch Spaß an groben Arbeiten,
aber auch Spaß an filigranen Arbeiten,
weil dieses kommt alles zusammen.
Und das von Minute eins an.
- Ein guter Anlagenmechaniker
muss logisch denken,
muss in Mathematik ganz gut sein
und muss im Prinzip auch
Spaß am Handwerk haben
und auch mit seinen
Händen arbeiten können.
- Die Ausbildung dauert dreieinhalb
Jahre und ist aufgeteilt
in schulische und praktische Arbeiten.
Man hat immer zwei oder einen
Tag in der Woche Schule
und den Rest ist man mit den
Kollegen unterwegs auf den Baustellen.
- Erstmal als Anlagenmechanikergeselle,
wenn man die Ausbildung fertig hat,
ist man Geselle. Da kann man auf
jeden Fall im Kundendienst arbeiten,
man kann auf Baustellen arbeiten,
man kann im Neubau arbeiten,
man kann sich natürlich
auch weiterentwickeln.
Man kann noch seinen Bachelor machen,
man kann seinen Master machen,
man kann seinen Meister machen,
man kann seinen Techniker machen.
Es gibt vielfältige
Entwicklungsmöglichkeiten
gerade in unserem Beruf.
- Mir gefallen am meisten
die Badsanierungen,
weil man da von Minute eins bei den groben
Arbeiten schon ganz genau arbeiten muss,
sonst wird das Endergebnis nicht
dementsprechend, wie es gewünscht ist.
Und das ist halt dieses Faszinierende,
dass man trotz ziemlich grober Arbeit
und Staub und Lärm und Dreck
schon extrem genau arbeiten muss.
Das erfordert eine hohe Konzentration.